mi piace
mettiamone ancora
il cellulare Siediti
[Musica]
Benvenuti su Anita Stories oggi nuovo
episodio della guerra degli scherzi
Frank Word Ciao organizzando uno scherzo
per Vitale parlo a bassa voce così non
mi sente
mi dovete vedere che scherzo sto
organizzando come negli altri episodi
andremo a farci degli scherzi presi da
five minutes crafts o one two three goes
o troomtroom E se questo episodio
raggiunge i 10.000 mi piace ci sarà
anche un altro episodio in più alla fine
del video scrivete nei commenti quale
scherzo Vi è piaciuto più di tutti ma
ora vi faccio vedere che scherzo sto
organizzando Allora ormai sapete che
Vitale mi ruba sempre il cibo e infatti
gli ho fatto altri scherzi con il cibo
ve li ricordate super divertenti questa
volta gli farò un altro scherzo con il
cibo e cioè prendo delle patatine Svuoto
la confezione
e dentro alla confezione metti
uno Slime schifoso Guardate questo Slime
è un mix di Slime Che cos'è questo Cos'è
nella confezione non so se ci sta
o no è troppo grande
devo togliermi un pezzo
sotto le mani dovrò fare in modo che
Vitale non si accorga che qua dentro non
ci sono le patatine
è una bellissima sorpresa Vitale
Vitale
Vuoi qualche patatina
[Musica]
Sì ciao
ho visto uno scherzo che è troppo
divertente Anche se ho paura che si
arrabbierà molto
perché questo scherzo È veramente
veramente cattivo me lo faccio subito
vedere questo spero che riuscirà questo
scherzo per prima cosa devo prendere una
tavoletta di cioccolata e scioglierla
Ecco la tavoletta di cioccolato che
metterò nella sedia ed Ah eccolo qua per
non attaccarsi alla sedia l'ho messo in
questa carta da forno Ora non mi resta
che scioglierlo e poi chiamare Vitale
sperando che si sieda senza accorgersene
per scegliere il cioccolato provo con il
phon
ok con il phon Ci vuole troppo tempo
Basta scioglierlo al forno senza farmi
vedere ok sciolto il cioccolato al forno
Guardate che bello Ah mi viene voglia di
mangiarla tutto assaggiamo di un pezzo
Uh Che buono Ok Ora lo sistemo nella
sedia e Chiama ruvitale dicendogli che
c'è un'urgenza che deve subito vedere
qualcosa così non si accorgerà Spero Ok
ragazzi ho posizionato la cioccolata qua
per fare in modo che Vitale non si
accorga dove si sta sedendo devo farlo
arrivare velocissimamente farlo sedere
velocissimomente sperando che si sieda
senza guardare la sedia
Vitale Sbrigati Guarda guarda
cosa cosa sta succedendo guarda guarda
guarda guarda guarda guarda il cellulare
Siediti
che cosa
Ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah
calda
e fammi vedere mamma
sto perdendo il cioccolato dappertutto
ma insomma Vitale queste cose si vanno
in bagno bellissimo
[Applauso]
No no
E adesso saremo qualcuno come faccio ad
andare ad aprire così
super divertente rieccoci qua ho
cambiato i pantaloni perché non potevo
rimanere in quelle condizioni è arrivato
Vitale la vendetta
Infatti le farò uno scherzo che prevede
una bottiglia d'acqua ho bisogno di
questo nastrino per legarli insieme
questo video in realtà l'ho visto o su
Tik Tok su Instagram non ne sono sicuro
praticamente qui ho già fatto un nodo a
questa bottiglia d'acqua e andrò a fare
l'altro nodo anche a quest'altra
bottiglia d'acqua creo così una specie
di peso e i con l'aiuto di un foglio e
della farina dai dai andiamo andiamo
Eccole qua siamo pronti vi faccio vedere
Guarda Anita
Guarda questa nuova Challenge riesci a
fare questo
lo conosci questa nuova Challenge
No ma non mi fido Però
vuoi provare
Challenge due bottiglie Sì praticamente
devi sollevare queste due bottiglie così
Devi cercare di tenere il più possibile
fermo un foglio con degli oggetti sopra
non l'hai mai provata No ma siccome ti
ho fatto degli scherzi malefici non mi
fido penso che sia un trucchetto un
tranello Va bene allora se non ti fidi
la farò da solo questa Challenge vincerò
non hai voglia di sfidarmi E va bene
fammela provare però tu allontanati ok
Sì certo devo solo metterti il foglio le
cose da tenere in bilico poi mi
allontano quindi devo solo rendere
queste bottiglie Eh le braccia
[Musica]
poi mettiamo queste bottiglie qui così
consiste nel ottenere due fogli che lui
belli dritta Com'è difficile No non
pesano così tanto dai e praticamente
bisogna aggiungerci delle cose sopra
bisogna aggiungere qualcosa che c'è No
non dovete devi stare attenta Non lo
devi far cadere capito di stare molto
attenta mi raccomando
com'è
[Musica]
cosa fare ma dove non ha funzionato
volevo fare questa cosa
ha funzionato a metà
un trucchetto non puoi aiutarmi addosso
Non ci credo guarda come eri arrivato i
miei pantaloni Vabbè che effettivamente
anch'io
invece che mi hai fatto sembrare come se
mi fossi cagata addosso a me mi fa
volare Dai
e non giochino molto
malefico Qual è stata lo scherzo più
malefico e più divertente Secondo voi
mettiamo ancora
basterà tutto questo chiesa proprio per
colorarli i capelli e adesso rimettiamo
questa parte della spazzola all'interno
abbiamo qui il palloncino e la nostra
penna con la graffetta appuntita pronta
a farla esplodere sulla testa di Anita
Allora lo devi aprire subito eh tieni
tieni
subito che scherzetto andrò a fare a
Vitale prima di iniziare lasciate un bel
mi piace su questo video lo scorso video
degli scherzi Vi è piaciuto tanto
tantissimo E questo video raggiunge i
20.000 mi piace e andremo a fare una
quarta parte in cui proviamo tantissimi
scherzetti guerra degli scherzi quindi
lasciate un bel mi piace e se non mi
seguite ancora su Instagram andate a
seguirmi il nome Anita Stories Se volete
Seguitemi anche su Tik Tok Mettetevi
comodi prendete i Popcorn e iniziamo
subito con il primo scherzo primo
scherzetto è perfetto per Vitale perché
Vitale mi ruba sempre il cibo e infatti
io ogni tanto lo nascondo Guardate un
po' qua Guardate
che cosa c'è qua
Ma no un pacco di patatine e ho in mente
uno scherzetto fantastico che ho visto
da uno due tre Go che mi avete scritto
no si dice in inglese one two three Go
Ok one two three Go Eccolo qua
[Musica]
questo era lo scherzetto Speriamo di
riuscirci bene Allora innanzitutto vado
a svuotare il pacco di patatine sperando
che Vitale non senta l'odore e non
arrivi subito e appena arrivato Merlino
per controllare
Ehi Merlino vuoi fare anche tu degli
scherzi a Vitale Mi raccomando tutti
devi alleare con me in questa guerra
degli scherzi non con Vitale Ok
grazie Grazie per questi bacini Grazie
Merlino e la mascotte della Story Family
prima cosa vado a svuotare la confezione
di Pringles
no Merlino non sono per te
e ora andiamo a mettere il gavettone qua
dentro spero di riuscirci no Merlino non
è per te no
no no no no sono per Vitale Cioè non
sono neanche per Vitale non puoi
mangiarli tu Merlino
Dai non ci rimanere male tu devi
mangiare il cibo per cani
non puoi mangiare le patatine Ok ragazzi
Ecco qua Ho riempito il palloncino
d'acqua Che cos'è questo Merlino
no non si mangia Merlino prova sempre a
mangiare tutto un po' come fare perché
mi stai dando la zampa non si mangia
comunque l'ho riempito abbastanza e
vediamo se ci sta dentro al pacco di
Pringles Spero di sì Vediamo
Oh no non ci sta ah ecco è entrato Ok
ora devo stare super attenta e
richiuderlo prima con questa parte e poi
con la parte di plastica così non se ne
accorge ce l'ho fatta L'unico problema è
che devo stare attenta a non far vedere
questa parte del palloncino Vitale così
lui aprirà i Pringles e gli spruzzerà
tutta la bomba d'acqua addosso Almeno
spero che funzioni Devo stare attenta a
coprire qua coprirò così con la mano ora
non ci resta che chiamare Vitale sale
vieni o qualcosa da mangiare
Eh hai fame hai molto issimo fame allora
lo devi aprire subito eh tieni tieni
Grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non ci credo ha funzionato benissimo
Mi dispiace se non quando mi sono
dimenticata di nasconderlo nascondiamolo
nascondiamolo nascondiamola Ah ah ah
bellissimo perché da qua è uscita
l'acqua e ha fatto Shh sembra una
Fatti la fontanella è uscito
tutto in testa Hahaha Sei arrabbiato Sì
però era troppo divertente
Meno male
sai che si bagna il muso Merlino fa così
non lo so è un po' strano diteci se
anche i vostri cani sono così strani che
ogni volta che si bagnano il muso fanno
così Per asciugarsi
primo scherzo riuscito
anche se Vitale ora è arrabbiato non
perché sei bagnato Ma perché non gli ho
dato le patatine e comunque volevo dirti
che Chi la fa l'aspetti aiuto e mi sono
dimenticata di dirvi alla fine del video
dovrete votare il vostro scherzo
preferito quindi guardate il video fino
alla fine visto che Anita Mi ha bagnato
con questo scherzo col palloncino ho
deciso di ricambiare il favore con un
palloncino ripieno d'acqua questo
scherzo l'ho visto dal canale one two
three Go
[Musica]
vediamo subito il necessario abbiamo
bisogno di un palloncino una penna o una
matita e una graffetta alle solite
graffette quelle per carta per documenti
Insomma è ovviamente un pochettino di
scotch Vi mostro subito come fare
Dobbiamo prendere la graffetta queste
graffette qui e dobbiamo tirare all'insù
il lato questo qui non è appuntito però
diciamo il lato dove finisce la
graffetta e lo andiamo a tenere proprio
qui sulla penna poi ci aiutiamo con un
po' di scotch questo infatti servirà a
bucare il palloncino che ripieno d'acqua
ne farò un gavettone sulla testa ah lo
Monterò sulla porta Ovviamente lo
fissiamo alla penna ed abbiamo qui la
nostra penna graffetta
pronta a fare esplodere in testa il
palloncino d'acqua ad alita adesso Vado
a riempire il palloncino d'acqua e lo
vado a mettere sopra la porta e vi
faccio vedere guardate Ho riempito il
gavettone che arriverà in testa ad Anita
e adesso con l'aiuto della sedia lo
Monterò proprio qua sopra con dello
scotch lo andiamo a fissare qua sopra
l'ho attaccato con lo scotch proprio lì
sulla porta e adesso attaccherò con lo
scotch anche la penna proprio
all'altezza del palloncino fatto abbiamo
qui il palloncino e la nostra penna con
la graffetta appuntita pronta a farla
esplodere sulla testa di Anita ho
posizionato tutto là sopra sia il
palloncino che la penna con graffetta e
sono non ci resta altro che chiamare la
vita Anita
vieni
hai sentito questo rumore là fuori
Non lo so ho visto qualcuno forse sono i
ladri vieni dentro e chiudi la porta
Sì vieni vieni vieni vieni a nasconderti
qui chiudi la porta chiudi la porta
veloce
Hahaha
Non ci credo come avevo detto prima
bisogna fare la aspetti
i piedi mangiati
un pochino arrabbiato sui capelli però
guarda
anche tutti i piedi
adesso avrei la mia vendetta Dove sono
le patatine che avevo messo qua
perché sono la metà
consiglio di Merlino li hai mangiate tu
di nascosto
quindi non mi aiuti
prossimo scherzo ho in mente uno scherzo
molto cattivo per Vitale Così impara a
farmi il gavettoni Vabbè che gliel'ho
fatto anch'io questo scherzo È molto
divertente ve lo faccio vedere subito
[Musica]
Ok per questo scherzo Ci basta il
cestino poi
un foglio di carta ne ho preso uno che
avevo già usato forbici scotch e Farina
Tra l'altro oggi Vitale sta usando dei
pantaloni neri quindi la farina si vedrà
ancora di più Non vedo l'ora di vedere
la sua reazione sarà super divertente
Ok ragazzi Ecco pronto il cestino una
volta che schiaccerà il pedale si aprirà
Ora devo solo mettere la farina qua
sopra
Ok tutto pronto
o no devo andare a farmi le mani
altrimenti se ne accorgerà poi mi devo
inventare una scusa per fargli aprire il
cestino potrei dire che è caduto
qualcosa dentro che c'è un topo dentro
tipo
tale mi hai capito qua vieni subito
subito c'è qualcosa qua dentro il
cestino
Come peggio per me vieni subito qua
vieni subito c'è qualcosa qua dentro si
stava muovendo si muove qualcosa dentro
al cestino c'è qualcosa che si muove
dentro il cestino Toc toc Chi è C'è un
topo tipo una lucertola Davvero Sì apri
la controlla Ah dobbiamo chiamare
perlino così se la mangia
e che cos'è quella
c'è la farina qua sopra perché stavo
pensando di farti dei biscotti
fai solo con la farina Devi prendere
anche gli altri ingredienti per farli
Beh ho iniziato a prendere questo gli
ingredienti e poi prenderò anche gli
altri Ma cosa te ne frega adesso se ti
sto facendo i biscotti è una torta o
qualcos'altro L'importante è che apri il
cestino per controllare quello che c'è
dentro Dai apri e controlla Controlla un
pochettino
non sento muoversi niente
[Musica]
che scherzo è questo guarda un po' i
pantaloni neri come sono diventati
Peccato che la maggior parte è finito
per terra Wow
Infatti altrimenti tutto quello che
avevo trovato addosso
no
che perlina diceva che cos'è questo
discorso almeno lo scherzo è riuscito
sui pantaloni neri Anche qui sto scherzo
che mi ha fatto prima Anita con la
farina devo dire che mi è piaciuta tanto
anche se mi ha sporcato i pantaloni è
stato davvero divertente questa volta
però farò lo scherzo io ad Anita e sarà
uno scherzo che avrà a che fare coi
capelli
sarà troppo divertente proprio come
questo video qui Guardate
[Musica]
le andrò a rubare la spazzola e farò una
piccola modifica questa spazzola
per favore che mi devo pettinare ti devi
pettinare Sì
ma i capelli corti e che c'entra avere i
capelli corti non li puoi pettinare è
strano perché tu non ti pettini mai come
non mi pettino
ti pettini con le dita
C'è qualcosa di strano No non c'è
proprio niente di strano e va bene ma
riportamela subito ok
grazie Ciao è stato un gioco da ragazzi
Allora per prima cosa dobbiamo togliere
questa parte qui e poi cercare di farla
uscire dai bordi facilissimo proprio
così
poi prendiamo il nostro amico ketchup e
lo mettiamo all'interno
mettiamone ancora
basterà tutto questo chiesa proprio per
colorare i capelli adesso rimettiamo
questa parte della spazzola all'interno
quasi fatto
profumatissima Guardate Non si vede
proprio niente a parte sotto che è un
po' fredda perché ovviamente il ketchup
stava in frigo e quindi un pochettino
fredda altrimenti non si vede proprio
nulla
perfetta proprio come faccio adesso però
a convincere Anita a pettinarsi si stava
truccando ma si era già pettinata la
vado a spettinare così lei è costretto a
venire qui a prendere la spazzola e
arrivi a tirarti avanti Sono un genio
Anita sì
[Musica]
via via via via via via via via via via
via via via sapere cosa ti salta per la
testa
non mi salta niente per la testa
stai bene così vero
è proprio qui la spazzola tieni
sento un odore strano di patatine fritte
la mia testa Sarà di patatine fritte
Giustamente ci hai mangiato sopra Dì la
verità Sì
ancora Dai mettila
cioè perché mi guardi così
che quadro
che hai fatto gli spaghetti i capelli al
sugo hai fatto Ah Ah gli è caduto tutto
anche troppo in testa
oddio oddio oddio
Ah ah ah ah Che schifo
quelli sapranno di Chi è Tiziano per
fare una settimana
così impara a fare gli scherzi No no ti
conviene scappare
via via via via Ah ah ah Hai visto cosa
ha fatto Vitale Mamma mia spazzola
questa melodia Guarda qua
ti consiglio di andare a lavare i
capelli perché altrimenti puzzeranno
tantissimo di Grecia Merlino vuole
mangiare il ketchup con i miei capelli
Aiuto no Merlino non si mangia
portatevelo patatine
e patatine
senza problemi Merlino è tutta colpa di
Vitale
mi ha messo in casa con i capelli ma tu
non puoi mangiarmi capito
morbido non è per te questo è poco poco
AH AH AH AH è tutto patatine che stanno
bene non mi lascia più Merlino Ciao
amore
[Musica]
Ma che stai facendo Ti stavo disegnando
i capelli Poi però ho sbagliato volevo
cancellarli
smettila
Francesco
Merlino vuole sempre sgranare tutta
che vuoi fare beh certo certo
oggi Vitale in vena di scherzi ma devo
dire che anche io mi piacerebbe fargli
qualche scherzetto vi ricordate L'ultima
volta che abbiamo provato gli scherzi di
1 2 3 Goku Com'è andata e se non ve lo
ricordate andate poi a vedere il video
Dopo questo video Comunque ho in mente
un po' di scherzetti da fare a Vitale
ora vi subito il primo scherzetto che
andrò a farli e sarà super divertente ma
voi Mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi
piace su questo video se questo video
raggiunge i 20.000 mi piace allora
faremo una terza parte in cui proviamo
gli scherzetti di 1 2 3 Go o di troom
troom o di dei five minutes Craft
Insomma Decidete voi quali scherzetti
volete che proviamo e alla fine del
video scriveteci nei commenti Qual è lo
scherzetto che vi ha fatto più ridere di
tutti anche noi vi diremo il nostro
preferito e se non mi seguite su
Instagram mandate a seguirmi il nome
Anita Stories Se volete Seguitemi anche
su Tik Tok e se volete entrare a far
parte della Stories Family cliccate
sulla campanellina qua sotto e ora
iniziamo subito con il primo scherzo
[Musica]
Merlino Sei pronto per il primo scherzo
sei pronto a vedermi senza denti
spaventerai
Secondo me no Però forse Vitale si
spaventerà Ok ho preso quello che mi
serve per questo primo scherzo
fondamentale la mela devo stare attenta
a Merlino perché Merlino Adora le mele
Infatti lo chiamiamo anche super belli
super bellino oppure Merlino poi un
pacco di Tic Tac che infilzeremo nella
mela per fare finta che siano i denti
Devo cercare di fare in modo che lui non
le guardi bene attentamente così e non
si renderà conto che in realtà non sono
i miei denti comunque iniziamo provo a
infilzare le Tic Tac nella mela spero di
riuscirci Ecco fatto ho fatto i due
buchi nella mela per inserire le Tic Tac
vediamo se ci stanno Ecco fatto guardate
qua Wow È troppo divertente sembra che
la mela abbia due denti e ora manca
un'altra cosa
lo scotch di carta lo scotch di carta
serve a fare in modo che sembri che mi
manchino due denti Infatti ne stacco un
pezzetto Dopodiché lo coloro di nero
Ecco fatto ovviamente voi non fate
questi scherzi a casa eh Siamo noi che
siamo pazzi e facciamo questi scherzi
assurdi cosa parlare
Che meraviglia
Ora non c'è tempo da perdere Merlino che
stai facendo Berlino sta cercando la
mela da mangiare no Merlino qua ora devo
chiamare Vitale vediamo se ci casca qui
un robot
nascondere le prove
Vitale o qualcosa da mangiare
Siediti Siediti Volevo chiederti se
avevi voglia di una mela perché no
sempre il momento di una mela Ok Però
prima gli do un morso io ok ok grazie
[Applauso]
[Risate]
vi fornivano visto questi bianchi e dei
sorridenti poi ti ho visto in bocca è
tutta sporca di nero
[Musica]
perché mi mancano i denti ma è un
pochettino non ci sei cascato Uffa
queste sono Tic Tac Oh no Merlino
Merlino Beh questo scherzo è riuscito un
pochettino non tanto
[Musica]
Ok allora visto che Anita mi ha voluto
fare questo scherzetto ho deciso di
rispondere con un altro scherzetto dei
miei questo nello specifico è una specie
di trucchetto di magia che ho visto dal
canale 1 2 3 goal è una specie di
levitazione dove sembra che la persona
sta volando e in realtà c'è il
trucchetto glielo andiamo a fare insieme
Ciao
vuoi fare lo scherzetto insieme a me
facciamo lo scherzetto alla vita sì
Allora per questo scherzetto ci serve Oh
un bastone poi ci serve
una scarpa perché la dovremmo mettere
dentro è la coperta per coprire tutto
vado a prendere la coperta Intanto
andiamo a coprire con la coperta questo
bastone poi dobbiamo solo infilare la
scarpa qui e fare questo effetto di
levitazione
le prenderà un colpo
Anita vieni
[Musica]
Ma che stai facendo
Stai levitando come una torta un
panettone
Merlino Dimmi la verità c'è qualcosa
dietro qua vero
[Musica]
Dov'è sparito Merlino
Ma c'è qualcosa di strano in quella
scarpa Dov'è Merlino Innanzitutto è
scomparso
No
ho capito il tuo trucco Allora
dovrei resistere di più però è stato
divertente dai
una figura che Merlino è un po' confuso
adesso
Vitale ha voluto farmi questo scherzetto
E allora tocca a me fargli uno
scherzetto adesso ma vi ha visto che
sarà
molto che cosa stai dicendo
è giunto il momento della mia vendetta o
in mente un bellissimo scherzetto di uno
due tre Go e spero che riesca ve lo
faccio vedere subito e questo qui
[Musica]
Avete visto Sembra super divertente
Spero che funzionerà su Vitale Spero che
sarà super divertente la sua reazione
Allora iniziamo subito vado subito in
frigo a prendere qualcosa da bere
Guardate che cosa ho trovato in frigo
ancora meglio dell'acqua perché
arancione in più anche le bollicine sarà
troppo divertente basta fare un taglio
qua dietro mi sembra proviamo assieme
speriamo di non sbagliare Lino vuole
bere
l'aranciata è super curiosa e vorrebbe
berla ma Merlino tu non puoi berla ce lo
zucchero Ecco qua il buco lo vedete non
è troppo grande perché altrimenti se ne
accorgerebbe ma è abbastanza grande per
far uscire una buona quantità di
aranciata e ora chiamiamole vediamo come
reagirà
lo scherzo Vitale
vieni a qualcosa per te
ho deciso di farmi perdonare per tutti
gli scherzi e ti ho comprato
un'aranciata buona l'aranciata Ma non vi
piace come non ti piace
mi piacciono tutte le cose con lo
zucchero Era solo per vedere se era uno
scherzo oppure no no Certo che non è uno
scherzo tieni tutto per te dai bevila
bevila bevila No Come mai era già aperta
C'è vedi che è aranciata
non ci credo No infatti mi sembra strano
che sia aranciato appunto
Merlino Ma che dici
puoi dare l'aranciata
mi devo fidare Merlino
infilati
Dai bevila non ti preoccupare
[Applauso]
No ma non è caduto pochissima dovevo
fare un buco più grande
non ci posso credere No no no Ferma
ferma
Ah Porco Dio
che brutto scherzo no grazie che
non ho fatto niente
No grazie grazie non ti preoccupare Te
ne farò altri di scherzi
dovrei stare attenta alla vendetta di
Vitale sarebbe stato troppo divertente
[Musica]
Allora per vendicarmi Ho deciso che le
farò uno scherzo un po' schifosetto e
cioè chiamerò Merlino lo farò sedere qui
sulla sedia e grazie all'aiuto di un
tortino al cioccolato una specie di
ciambellina al cioccolato la impasterò e
farò sembrare
qualcosina di molto schifoso che ha
lasciato Berlino sulla sedia siete
pronti vi mostro subito come fare
Andiamo da tortina che noi la tagliamo
così e proviamo a fargli una forma un
po' ambigua proviamo eh può uscire uno
scherzo perfetto Merlino vieni
Merlino
Eccolo bravo Ciao Merlino Ciao Ho
bisogno del tuo aiuto per fare lo
scherzo della vita
Bravo seduto seduto
che bravo che Merlino si è seduto sulla
sedia Ciao Merlino Ciao Saluta tutti
Ciao ragazzi
Io sono pronto Se mi volete sganciare
qualche crocchetta io lo accetto sempre
è vero Merlino Allora nascondiamo Questi
intanto
che Anita vieni a vedere Merlino che
bravo che vieni a vedere quanto è bravo
il nostro cagnolotto
Ma cosa stavate facendo
un po' di coccole lo accarezzavo è vero
non Merlino ricordati un odore strano
qua
hai mangiato qualcosa Io sì
Sento odore di cibo Merlino
C'è qualcosa di strano Ora controllo in
giro
Bravo bravo che è il momento di agire È
il momento di agire adesso siamo pronti
dentro questo cassetto forse
dove l'hai nascoste le cose da mangiare
Ma guarda che io non ho nascosto proprio
un bel niente Sento odore di cose da
mangiare
Merlino Che cosa hai combinato Oh no
Merlino ho fatto la cacca sulla sedia
andiamo vediamo
che schifo domani
al cioccolato
Ciao
una gomma
Perché Perché no ok
era buona questa gomma da masticare ti è
rimasto un po' attaccata al dito aiuto
vieni qua qua
Ahia ahia
ahia ahia
Non ti avvicinare
devo ricaricare quello che Vitale abbia
imparato la lezione che non mi faccia
più gli scherzi Benvenuti su Anita
Stories oggi nuovo episodio delle prime
Wars La guerra degli scherzi o degli
altri episodi ci saranno vari scherzi
che andremo a provare e voi alla fine
del video dovrete votare il vostro
scherzo preferito nei commenti lasciate
un bel mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 20.000 mi piace ci sarà un
altro episodio della guerra degli
scherzi Mettetevi comodi prendete i
Popcorn e iniziamo subito Ciao ragazzi
ho visto uno scherzo che secondo me è
perfetto per Anita ed ecco qua ho già
tutto Andiamo andiamo
[Musica]
cosa vuoi E tu che cosa stai facendo con
quello in mano mi sto proteggendo
quello che io non ho fatto niente questa
volta sarò attenta ok Meno male
sarò più attento alla prossima volta
puoi andare in un'altra stanza
non puoi aiutarmi a letto non
ce l'ho già Ciao Merlino Ciao ragazzi
Che schifo Oh no Allora
fammi vedere
era solo uno spruzzino e acqua Non ti
preoccupare
tocca a me fare un bello scherzetto
Vitale e ho in mente un bellissimo
scherzetto siccome Vitale mi ruba sempre
da mangiare Mi taglierò qua sotto
lascerò questo pacco di patatine
appoggiato qua sulla mia scrivania che
sicuramente cascare la trappola perché
ogni volta che vede il cibo Vitale va lo
prende e lo mangi e spero che funzionerà
li cadranno tutti addosso tagliamo ora
qua la parte di sotto e vediamo se
funziona sto tagliando la base con Il
taglierino Mi raccomando voi non fatelo
a casa perché può essere pericoloso
lasciate che li facciamo noi che siamo
pazzi è un po' scendi Ecco fatto la
scherzetto
è pronto Ora devo solo posizionarlo in
un punto un po' in alto così sono sicura
che li cadranno addosso fino Mi
raccomando tu Non dire niente a Vitale
Merlino ha visto tutto mi raccomando non
avvisarlo Non dire niente a Vitale Me lo
prometti che non dici niente a Vitale
Bravo Merlino ha promesso
[Musica]
posizionato ora mi basta Chiamare Vitale
e fare finta di niente e sperare che lui
noti subito il cibo Merlino sei pronto
Ora chiamiamo Vitale Ok Vitale
C'è qualcosa da mangiare qua
Sono il genio Vitale esprimi tre
desideri Ma come ti sei vestito che cosa
hai in testa volevo fare il genius
è impossibile perché sei troppo tonto
che volevi niente Volevo chiederti se
senti qualche odore strano qua mi devi
trovare qualcosa da mangiare Nascosto ma
secondo me tu mi stai facendo uno
scherzetto No nessuno scherzo
qualcosa qua dentro quindi per questa
volta non aprirò niente e mi limiterò a
rubare Solo questo Ciao
piccolo
Scherzo scherzo
giusto per te vieni qua sono morbidi
[Risate]
ma che fai tu hai mangiato le patatine
Ciao ragazzi
ciao ragazzi scherzetto super super
malefico per Natale
ho preparato un secchio di popcorn e vi
starete pensando ai popcorn Non sono uno
scherzo cattivo anzi sono buonissimi
Vabbè Loro sono buonissimi c'è Merlino
qua sotto che mi sta guardando con aria
famelica vi faccio subito vedere come
funziona questo trucchetto devo
semplicemente poggiare i popcorn al
soffitto prenderò una sedia Spero di
riuscire poi tenerli fermi con il
bastone della scopa puoi chiamare Vitale
e ti ritieni un momento fermo qua così
Lui prenderà il bastone e non potrà più
muoversi perché se si muove gli cadranno
i Popcorn in te Proviamo vediamo se
riusciamo a fissarli al soffitto
Speriamo pranzo c'è da qualche disastro
tipo che mi cadono addosso a me no Spero
di noce Merlino qua sotto che mi guarda
in modo strano e sta pensando ma che sta
facendo questo Humana ci sono riuscita
ragazzi tipo popcorn sono visti sul
soffitto mi fanno già male le braccia
devo subito chiamare vitale per
sostituirmi e poi vedere che cosa fa la
vita Ale
dove sarà mi fanno malissimo le braccia
vieni subito È un'emergenza in emergenza
vieni devi tenere questa tieni tieni
tieni tieni questo bastone Tienilo fisso
bene
se tu lasci andare col bastone ti
cadranno i Popcorn in testa quindi devi
rimanere così finché non ti faranno
malissimo le braccia e ti cadranno
comunque in testa Aspetta aspetta Ho due
soluzioni
La prima è che posso provare a lasciare
questa a prenderla al volo la seconda è
che mi metto a bocca aperta
così prova a mangiarli tutti No adesso
proprio che ci riuscirai come hai fatto
un'idea Secondo me
sei spacciato
accettiamo scommesse Secondo voi Vitale
quanto resisterà Così fermo con le
braccia ma scusa
no io devo tenere le distanze Casomai
popcorn cadono sulla mia di testa
scrivete nei commenti Secondo voi quanto
resisterà Vitale
secondo per 5 minuti non tanto bene
comincia a far male il braccio
Aiutami tu metti una zampa anche tu qui
Merlino stasera su giochino non gliene
frega niente di aiutarti
È troppo divertente questo scherzo
no questo è uno scherzo solo per te
lo sai che il prossimo scherzo che farò
io a te allora sarà Cattivissimo come
pensi di uscire da questa situazione
vediamo qual è il tuo piano mangiandoli
tutti i Popcorn ma è impossibile Ti
cadranno per forza addosso
mi metterò così
[Applauso]
[Risate]
per finire il risultato esatto
mandiamo qualcosa neanche uno ma tu sei
rimasto con la bocca aperta ma insomma
sei un pop corn in testa
Eccomi ragazzi lo scherzo di Anita è
stato super cattivo per questo che le
farò io adesso uno scherzo ancora più
cattivo ed ecco qui la maschera per il
viso le dirò che l'ho comprata apposta
per lei devo mettere qualcosa qui
all'interno devo mettere il colorante
altrimenti come fa a colorare la faccia
venite venite lo scegliamo insieme e
così allora vediamo qui che cosa abbiamo
a disposizione vediamo uh uh quanti
colori abbiamo la colla Rosa la colla
blu vi ricordate quello scherzo che
abbiamo fatto ad Anita con la colla che
era piena di colla in faccia se non ve
lo ricordate ve lo lascio qui nel
frattempo cerchiamo di scegliere altri
colori Guardate quante cose ci sono Uh
forse dovremmo scegliere proprio questo
colore qui il preferito di Anita
Wow Qui abbiamo anche il glitter
Guardate che cosa c'è qua dietro Wow
Ma questi sono colori bellissimi
decorazioni
coloranti qua dietro mmm credo di
scegliere proprio questo penso che il
colore giusto sia proprio questo secondo
voi quale sarà la reazione di Anita
questo scherzetto scrivetelo giù nei
commenti Eccomi Guardate Ragazzi ho
messo il colorante
Non vedo l'ora che reagisca Oh no mi
sono sporcato la vita idea allora Mi
inventerò che le ho preso la maschera
per fare una Spa in casa proprio qui
Vieni vieni che ho una sorpresa per te
Eh sì è una sorpresina per te no perché
sei arrabbiata perché non mi fido Ok un
regalo per te perché c'è la videocamera
lì
non lo so perché stavo facendo vedere
che ti stavo facendo la sorpresa La
sorpresa è la Spa in casa
Sì così ti puoi rilassare e puoi fare un
trattamento al viso aspetta un momento
Che cos'è questo ah stavo facendo uno
Slime l'ho dimenticato lì
ok
mi sono seduta cosa devo fare adesso
al trattamento specifico facciale della
maschera meravigliosamente fantastica Ok
sì sì prego si accomodi si accomodi si
rilassa e si stendi una volta
no Lo volevo solo togliere Prego si
accomodi si stende chiudo gli occhi Come
si chiama questa maschera per il viso
Questa si chiama la maschera verde no
nel senso Green nel senso che è fatta
alle erbe e quindi è verde
tocco completamente naturale fatta con
15 erbe della campagna
della campagna Sì perché è molto
naturale sono appena raccolte
esattamente Che ingredienti abbiamo
prezzemolo a loro e ok Com'è bella
fresca lo sente il profumo della natura
bello No Come no un attimo bello Quindi
quali sono questi ingredienti abbiamo
le mani sporche e nel senso abbiamo
abbiamo gli ingredienti di erba fresca e
appena appena tagliata poi abbiamo
spinaci e broccoli cicoria e zucchina Mi
sembra che stai descrivendo
gli ingredienti una minestra
così lo tenga almeno per 20-25 minuti il
tempo che faccia effetto lo spinacio Più
che altro
non si muova però perché sennò si scolla
e perde tutti i benefici della foglia di
limone
sembra un po' strana questa maschera
siete già siete già il profumo del
prezzemolo
[Musica]
con cosa con le verdure
C'è qualcosa di strano in questa
maschera o il pollice verde
non mi fido Io me la tolgo No no deve
fare effetto lo spinacio siberiano su
tutti gli astratti delle verdure
degli Ortaggi della frutta il prezzemolo
la carota no carota non c'entra ancora
5-10 minuti quindi sì no no lasciami
voglio Voglio toglierla
in effetti
è il grigio No non è il grigio questo
nella maschera
Questa me la paga Vitale ora si beccherà
queste cose Aspetta aspetta che c'è Hai
per caso pure tu il pollice verde
finalmente la vita imparerà a prendersi
cura delle Piante contro Zombi
ah ah smettila
questa me la paghi
l'hai scampata
ta Questa è uno scherzo più cattivo di
tutti smettila eh Smettila
[Musica]
sì
Avete visto Vitale sta dormendo fuori
nella sdraio in giardino ora io vi
porterò questa prima maglia la farò bere
un po' così non sospetterà niente Dopo
gli farò un bello scherzetto e se vi
state chiedendo ma come fai a sapere se
lui la accetterà e la berrà a Vitale
posso dare qualsiasi cosa da bere da
mangiare e lo avverrà in mangerà sempre
[Musica]
Ehi ragazzi ho preso la Pepsi e anche
qua la salsa di soia Però ho paura che
Vitale si insospettirà e se ne accorgerà
e non può vedere il colore attraverso la
lattina quindi mi è venuta un'idea la
metterò in un bicchiere anzi
in due bicchieri in un bicchiere metto
la Pepsi normale
[Musica]
invece nell'altro bicchiere
metto un po' di pezzi andiamo ad
aggiungere la salsa
[Musica]
Spero di non confondere i bicchieri
Questo è quello che spetta Vitale Invece
questo è il mio ma ora torniamo fuori e
andiamo a fare lo scherzetto Vitale
[Musica]
non ci piace
perché è salata me l'aspettavo dolce
primo scherzetto è riuscito secondo
scherzo
ho deciso di dedicarmi con la vita per
lo scherzetto di prima e quindi le farò
uno scherzetto io che cosa farò con
questo scotch la andrò a scocciare alla
sdraio la legherò alla sdraio con lo
scotch sostanzialmente
[Musica]
Buongiorno
Che cosa hai fatto
Non riesco ad alzarmi
Merlino Merlino è impegnato a
controllare le sue ciotole
il bambino Aiutami
si mangia
[Musica]
lasciala andare Merlino Merlino
vieni a liberarmi Bravo Merlino
mangia tutto lo scotch arrivo
Sì
sono libera
Ah no ci sono anche le gambe
[Musica]
terzo scherzo
Ok ragazzi siamo in cucina per
quest'altra scherzetto di 1 2 3 got
invece della panna Userò la maionese Non
so come far avvicinare Vitale al piatto
potrei dirgli che c'è qualcosa da
mangiare dentro ma deve riuscire a
vederla bene per mangiarla e poi Splash
gli spiaccico il piatto in faccia
Speriamo che ci caschi anche in questo
ma per gli scherzi con il cibo è molto
facile con Vitale
Ora vado a portare il piatto a Vitale
Speriamo che ci caschi
Io ho sempre fame
Assolutamente sì
Aspetta però non puoi guardare Che cos'è
È una sorpresa
non guardare è una crema devo prima
spiegarti come come è stato realizzato
questo piatto l'hai cucinato tu allora
non lo voglio cosa vuoi dire scusa eh
C'è qualcosa di nascosto in questo
piatto
devi guardare molto bene
[Musica]
Che senso ha mangiare con gli occhi se
non lo posso vedere molto bene dentro e
se riesci a vederlo lo puoi mangiare Ok
guarda un po' Guarda bene avvicinati
bene guarda
[Musica]
hahaha
Ma è maionese
sei contento di aver trovato questa
prelibatezza Perché il mio padroncino si
è mangiato la baionetta con la faccia
Allora non mi aiuti a pulirla
[Musica]
[Risate]
Merlino
ma anche tu ti sei sporcato tutto
quarto scherzo
E questa volta che cosa farò le andrò a
fare questo Trucco tutorial trucco ma
prima sostituirò la crema con
della colla Eh che ho detto questo
sostituirò la crema con la colla Insomma
quanta Anita
vieni
Prego si accomodi si secca qui
e sei contenta Finalmente il tuo
fidanzato ti fa un trucco
non mi fido molto tutti tutti
sperimentare con i trucchi Allora io lo
conosco bene tutto tutto i termini della
terminologia dei trucchi chiudi gli
occhi però che sarà a sorpresa
a sorpresa chiudi gli occhi Allora per
prima cosa chiudi gli occhi ha detto va
bene oggi per prima cosa Quanti sono
questi tre e come hai fatto a indovinare
Allora per prima cosa dobbiamo idratare
il viso Quindi mettiamo una crema
idratante Strano questo fatto che prima
bisogna mettere la crema idratante
è la cosa della crema idratante non lo
sapevo
E allora perché io me la stai mettendo
se non lo sapevi Eh perché li troviamo
bene la Fedele ha un motore un po'
strano Questa crema e perché è una crema
di nuovissimo generazione Ma che stai
dicendo questo è particolare
praticamente c'ha
il retinolo il secchitello
il retino il secchiello ha detto Cazzo
sì E dove l'hai comprata
no farmacia questa la vendono in
farmacia e che cosa hai chiesto quando
l'hai comprata per favore una crema
idrata altamente idratante e basta e
loro ti hanno dato questa Sì Tra l'altro
Guarda è famosissima Tra l'altro aiuta
proprio tanto la pelle respirare e tutto
e come si chiama Si chiama ehm
crema ad altissima efficienza
Questo è il nome della crema No Qual è
il nome della marca
non me lo ricordo mica Guarda nella
scatola nella scatola qui adesso e
quante domande in silenzio Sto facendo
io il tutorial trucco Allora dopo che
idratate Bene bene dappertutto
Voglio sapere il nome della crema
anti age Professional retinol
al Borotalco e crema crema pasticcera
L'importante idratare la pelle perché ho
una pelle idratata e una pelle bella ma
da quando ti interessano così tanto
perché
mi informo Guarda dove ti informi
Adesso invece andiamo a mettere il copri
pelle
il copripelle quello lì che c'è il
colore della pelle però
il fondotinta il fondotinta copripelle
non riesco a parlare bene con questa
crema speciale Dai sbrigati aspetta oh
io non è che sono pratico a fare queste
cose come si mette sul pennello non un
truccatore alle prime armi
professionista però eh Che bello Cioè ma
io sono bravissimo a fare queste cose
allora ottimo lavoro per il momento
Adesso dobbiamo mettere il colore a
guance
un attimo adesso deve fare effetto
Allora il colore aggancio Eh
praticamente Indovinate A che cosa serve
Serve a colorare le guance fantastico
colora guancia applicato adesso ultimo
tocco prima non chiudere non aprire gli
occhi eh Chiudi Ok ultimo tocco Non ti
muovere labbra
un attimo non credo sì Questo non lo so
come si mette Adesso sono un artista sei
Sei bellissima hai finito credo proprio
di sì puoi aprire gli occhi
[Applauso]
Che cosa hai messo
qua nel mio cuore la faccia bellissima
sicuramente resiste all'acqua bellissimo
tutto
resisterà all'acqua sicuramente non sei
contenta
[Musica]
poi uscirà la maschera della mia faccia
Ma come l'hai messo questo rossetto
davvero
che tu non abbia preso le mie
sopracciglia No per niente proprio
Quindi sei soddisfatto di come ti ho
truccato No ora te la mette in faccia Sì
sì aspetta aspetta
Ah le sopracciglia
capelli Eh sì forse era rimasto
incastrato qualche capello non ne sono
sicuro
Spero che almeno mi abbia tolto i punti
neri Ecco la mia faccia
sembra una cosa dell'orrore
però almeno non ti devi struccare entra
nel rossetto vieni
qua io scappo Ciao Merlino Oh Merlino
andiamo dai prova a farti vedere una
cosa gigantesca
Non ho parole
che puzza puzza tantissimo Si è
incollato anche i capelli tra l'altro
[Applauso]
una castagna
mettiamo dell'uva come reagirà a Vitale
Secondo voi
Ciao ragazzi
ho comprato tutti questi calendari
dell'avvento di cibo sembrano super
interessanti Guardate che grande Questo
pesa tantissimo Non vedo l'ora di
aprirli e mangiarli tutti C'è solo un
problema se Vitale li vede li vorrà
mangiare letteralmente tutti nascondono
qua nella camera e voi vi lascerò qua a
controllare la stanza così potrete
avvisarmi se Vitale è entrato e ha
mangiato qualcosa Merlino Tu non fare la
spia eh Non dire dove li ho nascosti
altrimenti Vitale li mangerà tutti
quindi mi raccomando non dirgli niente
Ok a fare fatto fare fatto bravissimo
vi faccio vedere dove ho nascosto i
calendari così potrete sorvegliare
meglio la stanza uno è qua un altro e
qua non lo trovo neanche io bene Vuol
dire che l'ho nascosto bene Comunque qua
sopra è uno qua sopra ed è verde quindi
si mimetizza con il verde qua dietro
sotto al letto Voi lasciate un bel mi
piace Mi raccomando se volete vedere
altre Challenge di cibo se questo video
raggiunge i 20.000 mi piace faremo
un'altra Challenge di cibo
consigliatecelo pure nei commenti se non
mi seguite ancora su Instagram andate a
seguirmi il nome Anita Stories Se volete
Seguitemi anche su Tik Tok il nome è
sempre Anita Stories ora iniziamo subito
la Challenge
Sento odore di cibo che cosa hai fatto
Merlino hai nascosto del cibo qua dentro
cos'è questo
Jelly Beans caramelle Sì cibo cibo
oggi è proprio il mio giorno fortunato
le appoggia qui e le mangerò tutte dopo
qualcuno qui ha nascosto del cioccolato
tutte tutte Allora Merlino io ne
appoggio qui Tu non dire niente Facciamo
un patto io mi metto qui mangio tutto e
dopo ti porto a fare la passeggiata Va
bene Ok Affare fatto cos'è questo
pop corn Wow
bene Pronta la sessione di degustazione
Mettiamoci comodi vediamo che cosa
abbiamo qui da degustare insieme vediamo
vediamo quale numero apriamo numero 9
apriamo così oh no sale aceto Ma sono
quelle che a me non piacciono Vabbè non
fa niente Le mangerò comunque
Sto ammirando la mia bellissima
collezione di libri
ho sentito un rumore strano meglio
andare a controllare
[Applauso]
queste cose Merlino te l'ha chiesto era
lui che voleva mangiare Non ci credo
Merlino aveva fatto un fatto con me che
li teneva tutti nascosti
adesso inserisco tutti
Cosa sono questi sono buonissimi ostaggi
ti consiglio anche questo è il
cioccolato
focolati
[Musica]
ho fatto bene o no allora no no non ho
fatto sì non è possibile Avevo nascosto
tutti questi calendari per fare la
Challenge in cui mangiavamo il cibo del
calendario degli eventi per 24 ore Ma tu
li stai già finendo E qual è il problema
Ok allora è iniziata Tu hai già fatto
colazione pranzo
Adesso mammate tutte e due devo mangiare
io il pranzo Prima che vi finite tutto
via ciao ciao ciao
Dove lo stai portando questo via con me
per mangiarlo no pensi che non ti ho
visto che hai rubato un altro pacco
vieni qua
Ciao
è vuoto Vieni qua vieni qui scappando
Guardate Che disastro che ha fatto
Vitale guardate
ha lasciato solo queste le caramelle
sapete perché le ha lasciate Perché
queste possono anche avere dei sapori
disgustosi possiamo elaborare assieme un
piano fai un bello scherzetto prenderò
uno di questi calendari lo svuoto e lo
riempio con qualcos'altro così avrà una
bellissima sorpresina per merenda Vitale
Vabbè io inizio ad aprirle
che cosa Apri che cosa apre aspetta
aspetta aspetta
cosa sono delle caramelle
buonissimissimissime
da Merlino tu non puoi mangiarle eh
Allora Aspetta fammi controllare una
cosa vuoi controllare questa
pesca Io adoro pescare niente non ti
posso dire niente Io adoro la pesca
Grazie Fammi sapere che sapore ha
Che sapore ha boh ah ah ah che sapore
Haha di che cosa sta No fa schifo
fa troppo schifo Che cos'è È andata male
Beh è semplicissimo e sta pure vomito ah
ah Che schifo cosa impari a mangiare
tutto il cibo nei miei calendario
vediamo che cos'altro Abbiamo qua
dammene un'altra una buona
che cos'è No non la voglio se puzza non
la voglio Merlino
puzza terribile
potrebbe essere un liquirizia oppure
puzzola spray vestito quindi
scoregge di puzza
Merlino
Ma perché no no no ti devo tenere io
Questa potrebbe essere o pera o caccole
Mmm
Dai mangia senza odorare vai
Che cos'è
No fa schifo è peggio di quell'altro eh
eh
merda di caccole Che schifo questa
non lo devi annusare No che puzza
assaggia no Devi assaggiare io l'ho
assaggiate due brutte Eh tieni questa te
lo regalo
Ora io per te E va bene allora
sicuramente mi capiteranno quelle buone
Dov'è il numero 2 Merlino sta ancora
sperando di mangiare la scorreggia di
puzzola ma finalmente non è che puoi
mangiare sono tantissimo quelle numero 2
c'è una puzza incredibile eccola qui Uh
Qua c'abbiamo qualcosa di nuovo mi sa
Mmm aiuto apriamole e vediamo allora io
la scelgo bendata però tu dimmi quale
dei due genitori può essere poi Ok Hai
scelto questa io intanto non resisto
Quindi ne prendo uno anch'io
boh quello che ho preso io fa schifo o
formaggio con la muffa che è quella che
ho preso io probabilmente oppure popcorn
al caramello al caramello non è male in
effetti Ecco qua Ragazzi c'è un'altra di
quelle nere che potrebbe essere un
liquirizia puzzola ho scoreggia di puzza
a giudicare dalla faccia di Merlino
potrebbe essere che correggere la
puzzola
io mi butto e lavaggio la mangio senza
pensarci vediamo
non ci credo che fortuna Questa Bianca
potrebbe essere Oh cocco oppure latte è
andato a male
non ci credo ma neanche una buona è
andata male allora apriamo l'ultimissima
perché poi faremo merenda e poi dobbiamo
fare la cena quindi non possiamo
mangiarli tutti Adesso
sì abbiamo trovato tutti i frutti e ce
ne sono due così una per me una per
Vitale che tutti i frutti potrebbe
essere o tutti i frutti appunto oppure
calze puzzolenti
vediamo Io tutti i frutti Ecco qua le
due tutti i frutti una è tutti i frutti
e una calza puzzolenti quale scegli
questa
Merlino come ti fanno il piacere le
calze a te non ho bisogno che sapore
hanno queste calze a terra sudore
quale scegli
anche tu la devi prendere vai
non ci credo
no e cioccolato Allora per l'ultimo
turno ne prenderemo una casa a occhi
chiusi senza guardare il colore senza
guardare Che cosa significa senza
guardare niente Ok inizia tutto ok
Vediamo se questa volta mi capiterà
qualcuno
Ecco qua il colore bianco cocco
e cocco Non ci credo non ci credo come
fai Non ci credo
non dovevi guardare
Che cos'è
popcorn salato tipo
che cos'è
[Musica]
Così impari a prenderne due Che cos'è
uovo marcio
bene questa Challenge sta andando alla
grande
Ragazzi sto mangiando ma nel frattempo
sto anche preparando lo scherzetto per
Vitale ora vi faccio vedere
Guardate un po' ho preso un po' di cose
sane come frutta frutta secca Qua c'è
Merlino che sta cercando se c'è qualcosa
da mangiare da rubare no Merlino non
solo per te queste cose quindi
sostituirò nelle caselline con queste
cose sane
no Merlino no Merlino non è per te il
mandarino una castagna
qua Merlino sta facendo il mio
assistente
come reagirà a Vitale Secondo voi
mettiamo dell'uva
con dentro frutta secca
lui si aspetterà i cioccolati le
caramelle ma invece no è il momento
della cena chiamiamolo subito nascondere
queste cose
questa la mettiamo qua
Vitale pronta la cena
quello che troviamo nel calendario
dell'Avvento Ovviamente
poi ci sono miei professori 1 Ma io te
l'ho fatto assaggiare le Pringles prima
va bene solo uno
dai scarta pure il calendario per la
cena
Eh allora vuol dire che mi devi aprirne
un'altra
non c'è niente Questi li abbiamo aperti
tutti prima
una castagna hai visto che strano ma
dobbiamo cuocere amica si può mangiare
così un altro castagna No ma io voglio
il caramelle
e mi dispiace sono finite visto che ne
hai mangiato troppe ma non c'è
nient'altro due castagne
c'è qualcosa che si muove qua dentro
Ma è una noce
a cena così impari a rubarmi il
calendario di nascosto
[Risate]
ho trovato un'altra cosa qui con un
altro noce
No io c'ho due castagne
ormai hai dimenticato di prendere quella
le cose
abbiamo anche dell'uva qui
Ma come sono la frutta secca la frutta
vera
ma non ti preoccupare perché c'è altro
c'è Mandrino
medaglia alla fine e poi c'è altra
frutta secca
Wow
uffari Questa sarà la tua cena
qualcos'altro no
mi hai mangiato tutto
Hahaha
Lo prendo ho trovato un'altra cosa
[Risate]
bene Quindi tu mangia pure la tua
sanissima cena Io devo ancora aprire
questo al cioccolato bellissimo
tutte cose strane Per sentirmi meglio
grazie ciao ciao
Ciao ciao
Hahaha
Vieni qua vieni qua
vieni non è possibile Vitale è scappato
via dalla casa pur di rubare i calendari
con i dolci Incorreggibile che freddo io
rientro dentro sta troppo piccolo
è tornato smettila di mangiare lasciate
un mi piace se volete vedere altre
Challenge di cibo Vitale ne sarà molto
molto contenta
Ti lasciamo Qua quattro caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quello che preferite il
cioccolato insieme Ciao mangiate tanta
frutta e verdura così vi farà bene
starete bene non vi verrà la nausea